- First up, coming in, Roshan saying,
"I'm an introvert, being introverted,
how can I develop my
communication skills?"
What advice would have
there for introvert Roshan?
- Hey Roshan, now I've got
some great news for you.
I'll use a couple of other
quotes actually from people
I think both Evan and I respect,
who are amazing,
but they're introverts and
I think we often forget,
we kind of have, I think actually,
part of social media and
the celebrity culture,
you kind of expect everybody
to be an extrovert out there.
But they're not, when
people are very authentic
a lot of people are introverts.
You know, Evan shared with you before
on previous broadcasts about you know
how he's overcome and maybe
he'll talk a bit about that
today but one guy we both met and we think
pretty amazing entrepreneur,
Richard Branson,
his quote is "I had to train
myself into become more
of an extrovert."
I mean we've both met the
guy, he's just very humble,
super nice guy, cares
passionately about customers,
always looking for the way
to disrupt an industry.
And then another one from a
completely different field,
someone who wrote all the
legendary Harry Potter books,
JK Rowling, she said, "I've
been writing almost continuously
since the age of six, but
I've never been so excited
about this idea like I have
then. But my intense, immense
frustration is I didn't
have a pen that worked,
and I was too shy to ask
anybody if I could borrow one."
You know, and that's
one of the most numery
authors of our times.
And then someone in our
industry, Bill Gates,
whose done amazing philanthropic
work around the world
and leading massive campaigns
to do things like stop malaria,
and obviously built Microsoft.
And he kind of acknowledges,
you know I think introverts
can do pretty well.
If you're clever you can
learn to get to the benefits
of being a really good introvert,
about thinking about really top problems.
About kind of reading
everything you can just to
push yourself very hard,
to think of the edge and
beyond the edge of your area.
But you'd better team
up with some extroverts
that kind of do and tap
into both sets of skills,
so that you can build a company
and thrive both the deep thinking
but building a team also
to go out to the world
and sell those ideas.
So what does that mean?
It means there's a lot of
people around the world
you should feel very comfortable,
you know that a lot of
great business people,
a lot of great entrepreneurs
are absolutely introvert.
And I think my most sort of humble advice
would be with all these things
is we talked about with people
like Martin Luther King,
take that first step on
that giant staircase,
and the easier, you know the
more you pitch your idea,
the more you pitch it
to friends and family
in the society, in the environment,
more confidence you get.
And you can definitely overcome
your level of introversion
and be very successful.
What are your thoughts Evan?
Cuz you know you've been very
you've shown a lot of humility
and humanity in this topic
and it's a very personal topic to you.
- Yeah, I mean we talked about this
in the last one or time before
how we were both introverted.
And it may not always feel like it,
watching us on these sessions
but we're both introverted.
And first of all I think
it's just understanding that
being an introvert can
actually be a strength for you
in the ability to communicate.
Because yes you have to learn to talk,
but you have to learn to talk in a way
that other people can understand.
I think introverts
actually do a better job
of listening so that you can
understand the other person.
And so where extroverts
maybe need to do a better job
of listening,
introverts have that already,
and so just tapping into
that listening ability,
to know what they want, to
hear what they're excited about
and then give them a
message that will hit home.
And so first off for me would just be
disassociating the idea that
because I am an introvert
I can't be a success at
being a communicator.
Well you can, you just
do it in a different way.
You do it by listening really intently
and then sharing your message.
You don't have to be yelling
at the front of a stage
to communicate, there's
a lot of different ways
to get your message out there.
I don't think you should,
I don't think you need
to become that person
who's yelling on stage.
Go all in on your strengths,
and use that ability to listen really well
to give a message that
really resonates with the
person that you're trying to connect with.